so let me ask you have you ever had
anybody say any of these things to you
and when they do what happens to your
belly baby we need to speak Patrick we
need to speak right now honey you know I
love you but there are some things I
want to bring up to your attention there
are a few things that happen last week
that I want to talk to you about
tomorrow I need to see you in my office
now today I want to talk to you about
the three different styles we all have
when a stressful situation like that
just comes up I'm Patrick we have your
host evaluate a man weekly and real
quick before we get into the scene Paul
Munoz I want to give you some love here
thank you for the iPhone 6 I did a
crowdsource on social media you got back
to me you got some how to give me the
iPhone six-plus thank you thank you
thank you everybody else with the Droid
user guess what come to the dark side
the best phone in the world the iPhone
right Mario it is a dark side yes it is
a dark side Samsung Galaxy s5 user has
no clue what he's doing anyway so
today's message all right so a couple
months ago we read Crucial Conversations
right great book I thought it was one of
the best books I've read of read on this
subject here to the point where I went
and attended a seminars of the seminar
of theirs last week in San Diego two-day
seminar I highly recommend anybody and
everybody who is a CEO anybody in a
leadership position to attend the
seminar it's a smaller setting roughly
20 or 30 people or cost you 1500 bucks I
think is what the cost was and the
instructor goes through your roleplay
everything it's exceptional exceptional
training and they'll give you a workbook
worksheet two days teamates it was great
one of the things about Crucial
Conversations is they talked about two
different sizes that we all go through
where when a person is about to have
that conversation with us and it's
getting us very nervous our belly gets
nervous we get stressed out we get
anxiety we get upset and we typically
react in one of two ways one of them is
complete violence where you have a
mental breakdown
tell me if you've ever had a mental
breakdown like this before
that's tomorrow and that is it for us
today okay I don't know what
whatever it is it's not right on the
teleprompter I don't know what that is
I've never seen that no there is we are
gonna do sting yeah okay but just now I
can't read it there's no there's no
words on it okay hey there's no words
there to play us out what does that mean
to play us out its sting is going to do
it's a video sting video what is four
credits I don't know what that means to
play us out what does that mean
to end the show yeah yeah all right go
go in five four three that's tomorrow
and that is that again
five four three that's tomorrow and that
is it for us today and we will leave you
with a I can't do it we'll do it live do
it a lot doing live I can all write it
and we'll do it live and thank sucks so
how do you think the camera guy feels
after what all Riley just did to him
right you ever had a breakdown like that
before now obviously the thing about
breakdowns is it normally happens in a
smaller setting so not everybody sees we
look so good on the outside and we walk
around so polished and great but we had
breakdowns with family friends relative
coworkers happen to the best of us right
second one is the silence treatment so
you're either extremely violence or
you're totally silence and you can't
read someone's mind that's in this scene
an example like this
so we going in there
have you ever had that silence treatment
before have you ever had that feeling
where you can't really read the other
person's mind
so what Crucial Conversations says is in
every argument in every crucial
conversations they have the violence and
the silence but there's three things
that typically happen one is fight which
you could go some like this
you're funny of course I love you what
are you talking about Mario I'm not
afraid of it at all are you kidding me
all right I love you Mario I love you so
much
no seriously well I'm not even joking
seriously um did you get all the Reapers
from they've given gay game bro bro get
the hell out of my face what's wrong
with you you know what that is that
right get out of here bro Circe is the
stupid [ __ ] crummy there it's a
freaking gummi bear get over it
everybody ate a bro right I can birthday
it's done give me give me give me a
second
bro get out of my face right on the hot
oh that freaking smash it over we'll get
out I should be able to be on get out of
here nobody wants talk to you get out of
here
don't eat my gummy bears damn sorry
about that mate freaking people here man
second one is flight that it could go
something like this so Mario yeah so
we're gonna have just on my fiber web I
just answered that five minutes ago
yeah well it's for 52 and we need my
five what do you want man I'm trying my
best so I'm here you know we have a
couple minutes I'll get it done are you
almost done with her well we got we got
hard deadlines here bro yeah yeah it's
gonna it's gonna get done I can't have
it I can't have that's gonna get done by
get it done or so cuz I quit I'm done I
can't do this I can't have another
problem I'm done
oh god are you serious get it done
button and the last one is fries that
looks like this Mario Mario can work hey
what's going on I just want to make sure
we're cool man I apologize for the old
gummy bear thing so I make sure we're
good man I just want that to come
between us yeah I'm okay here
I saved you one yeah I'm okay now are
you sure it's a green one no it's fine
don't worry about it I'm good seriously
you can tell me I can buy more gonna go
to that
I got another price clubbing you a cost
I'll get five gallons of
seriously I wanna make sure we're doing
this one make sure everything is okay
now obviously there's a lot of different
versions of fight/flight and you know of
fries and in our personal lives without
a lot of examples of these but the
question becomes every time we go
through this and we have friction with
another person you know and if we find
we go to sleep at night upset because of
what we said we we didn't like what we
said right if we have the flight we are
subset upset now because we didn't
necessarily resolve that challenge with
that friend relationship whoever it is
we know we're missing that person the
only reason your emotions get high is
because you care about that person more
we don't typically have fight/flight and
fries with people we don't care about
it's typically people that are important
in our lives and if it's fries you're
not giving the other person a chance to
be able to know how to improve their
relationship with you so this is my
challenge to you Crucial Conversations
on the website vital smarts has a quiz I
want to encourage you and challenge you
to take it's a 33 question quiz it's
finding out your style when it comes
down to stress it's a true and false
answer questions for you to find out how
you react to it
and what you can do to improve yourself
when you're having crucial conversations
with somebody else and if attending one
of their conferences is within your
budget it can afford $1,500 I highly
encourage you to go and find out a local
seminar dear heaven in your place
they're all over the country all over
the world they do their seminars attend
their two-day seminar you'll get a lot
of value from it so my message of the
week Jim please be sure to subscribe to
this channel and comment on the bottom
Mauri if you're gonna interrupt us in
the middle of the video can you do me a
favor grab me at least some gummy bears
did you literally finish the whole thing
it was full just this morning come with
gummy bears gummy bears Oh last
character oh how many more laps you want
to do during the video today I want to
talk to you about
I'm sorry they felt totally forgot it
was your birthday oh oh oh
did you seriously call the Gophers
seriously dude oh yeah that will school
it's missing some they do get on dummy
bears it's seriously just back away
great freakin kidding I'm calling my
girl they did you dolly going girls I
don't I don't want to hear about your
freaking gummy bear control everybody
ate them
okay I didn't have any Enoch gummy bears
okay go away dude we'll talk outside